[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
steady
[Music]
[Music]
funny
[Music]
here we go
[Laughter]
hey [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here oh
[Music]
sean
tell me that first one
oh
we better be in the shade
oh wow
[Music]
down
david
[Music]
i'm just kidding hold on
behind
[Music]
i know you're going all the way down
yeah one
two three four five
[Music]
points
oh
oh
is
[Music]
[Applause]
always wins always wins
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
force
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
more
morse
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
absolutely
hey
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
jesus
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good afternoon yale college class of
2021
[Applause]
welcome to the graduates of brantford
[Applause]
morse
pearson
say brooke
and timothy dwight colleges
[Applause]
[Music]
and welcome to family friends and
members of the class who are joining us
virtually today
via live stream we are so excited to
have arrived at this special day
in a few moments we will begin
announcing the graduates as they process
across this stage here in front of me
but before we start our program a few
words about the land
on which today's ceremony is taking
place
yale acknowledges that indigenous
peoples and nations including mohegan
mash and tuck at pequot eastern pequot
and the quinnipiac and other algonquin
speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations the
lands and waterways
of what is now the state of connecticut
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship
that exists between these peoples and
nations and this land
thank you and please enjoy the program
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from sabra college for the
bachelor's degrees in yale college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these
degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college when designated by the
dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
henry maxwell jacob banner bearer of
saber college
benjamin samuel grobman and megan marie
sardis
the procession marshals of sabre college
john cenado ago
jonathan frederick altman
brooke christina alviar
nicholas anderson mia
arias sang jason
luis arroyo mappy
bakery mario baroques
luke peter griffith benson
kelsey taylor bowen
sydney jordan bowen
ryan joshua kane
sophia harp sophia hartman caro
brianna m carter
joshua peter chelli leo
chen shamiq didda
chaudry caleb hume
clothier curtis wiley covet
ekaterina danchenko
nicholas charles dewalt
arthur alastair donald
sarah elizabeth force
[Music]
jacob tobin gluckman
[Applause]
joao angelo gonzalez cardoso
emma rose gray
rohan krishna guram
a holly
[Music]
noah faith hines
marlena hinkle
[Applause]
eric fenner hirsch
[Applause]
anna cisco howard
courtney paige howard
amber roy who
[Applause]
evan grace hughes
chantinew rajesh ja
karen yang
[Music]
harry augustus khan
[Music]
ben caslos yev
young kim
emma blue kirby
aaron moss kleiner
adam sal crock elizabeth
ann leonard
zhen hao lee
asher joseph lifton
brandon john lopez
[Music]
owen alexander marks
[Applause]
david leopoldo mccowan
maria rose mckinney
[Music]
catherine cahill molaris
nicholas adam moscoso
william scott mukamal
jesse brian nadel
[Music]
aiden august o'connor
[Music]
samuel woman preston
skyler ruby regan
antoinette dibble roberts
elise rhiann robinson
anthony steve roras estrella
carlos ulysses rodriguez-cortez
justin dillon schneiderman
molly golda shapiro
[Applause]
superman preet singh
ryan thomas steele
rafael linder steiner
amanda giselle thomas
[Applause]
allison jane vandenbundt
lara victoria varela kaczynski
michael e vargas
christopher g west
august elliott white
felicia lauren wilkov
alice guanyi wu
bradley yam lee young
[Music]
[Applause]
you
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from timothy dwight college
home of the red lions for the bachelor's
degrees in yale college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
kangri john sullins the banner bearer of
timothy dwight college
[Music]
lena wy chan and alexander costell
demeglio the procession marshals of
timothy dwight college
[Applause]
etan samuel axe
[Music]
ziad abed ahmed
landon matthew allen
summer ali boy
rebecca lena amanor
grace morgan bartlett
joshua charles beasley
reza elias bergerman
india shannon shanthi balalad
brittany felicia boyce
alexandra eureka boyd
neil rahul braganza
sarah nicole cameron
deja kaleilani chappelle
marianne rebstock cosgrove
[Music]
mariana costellitos
karina daniela defranco
elizabeth lee dolan
owen beals duke
elias kareem farhat
aaron lee gerardo
shannon caroline guerra
harry andrew hegeman
[Applause]
jacob christian highnish
eleanor ida iskander
spencer travis johnson
[Applause]
tall joseph
tyler joseph jost
maluk khan
nashanth krishnan
derek amur cool to know
alessandra larocco
alexander ian latham
ariadne latrue
avi lee
erica vivian lynn
christina von lindsay
rashendra mcgunty
anusha monglik
michaela mapotoringa
jacob ruben paul mezzie
ananth miller murray
angel mora diaz
austin phillips o'toole
ali olson jonathan
michael palacios jacob payne
anna rose polish
anna merrill mcclure razad
camila rivera soto
henry rosas ibada
saul isaac roselar
sophia joy ross
gabriel victor roy
alejandra salazar gonzalez
josh samantha ray
christian levan sampleton
[Music]
sharia singh
[Music]
robert francis garonski
isaac donnelly swift
seatte to delay
antolik tran
elias armand johannes voss
emery zellers wallace
rhianne michelle wong
kenneth schuber nahom
imam and participating remotely
lauren jihyon kim lucy silba
and thomas shannon this man
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from morse college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer on them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
zachary william miller banner bearer of
morris college
lorenzo vasily arvanitas
and ava nicknahad marshals of morris
college
[Applause]
nicholas ryan abusolov
mustafa emir actera
justin oben
micah
[Music]
[Applause]
brigitta my burgess
[Music]
lucille francis burton
natalie jasmine bosomaker
alexander alexandrovich budawetsky
alana calais
thomas edward carrillo
nathan alexander chang
allison chen
[Applause]
cronin
maria elena cunningham
anastasia rose dalianes
paige hopkins davis
jonathan william duber
christian reed duvall
[Applause]
joshua mark diaz
[Applause]
haley isabel
lillian grace gold
jeremy goldwasser
derek kenneth gautier
julia charlotte guerrari
samuel howard grove
megan lara alexandra gupta
tanisha
[Applause]
nora marie heaphy
ariel m shea
colleen margaret huffman
karthik ericom
hale gordon jager
isabella rose jennings
claire sally calichmann
isla khan
[Music]
james curtis large ii
[Applause]
jake joseph levin
sandra lee
[Applause]
stephanie marie malta
brian callahan matthews
hannah comey melchinger
catherine claire morneau
[Applause]
courtney monique nunley
[Applause]
chaitan anthony pobik
nicholas armand padden
dante michael paleco
nikhil sunjay patel
samuel timothy piccarek
jordan cunningham perry
[Applause]
j brandon james linton peterson
daniel antonio peta
[Music]
sean william radgowski
benjamin colton rob
ian michael salvamoser
erasmus peter lillios schlitter
[Music]
matthew brian sparrow
abishek srinivas
[Applause]
zachary carl stanek
armin matthew thomas
adam neil tucker
[Applause]
cameron matthew warfield
nicole marie waters
[Music]
lily weisberg
[Music]
tyler harrison welsh
harry davidson westbrook
leah hannah
daniel dove yadine
[Applause]
[Music]
and graduates participating remotely
matthew herr
renee lynn ong parker duquesne red cross
evan michael schaefer
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from brantford college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun
will ask you by your official act to
confer
upon them these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college when designated by the
dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
the banner bearer of branford college
athena renee flint shall heavet
schwartz procession marshals of
brantford college
anissa kim abood
[Music]
[Applause]
joseph david allen
valentina amate perez
lakshmi rivera i mean
nicholas archambault
[Applause]
isabella marie back
alec jean bernal
gabrielle gene brannon
michael tao
kevin jay young ciao
[Applause]
gabrielle calangelo wesley
day
celia vanessa de leon
[Applause]
david o'conn adimo
[Applause]
rohankar
lewis elijah goldsmith
andrea gordon detzki
aisa janae gindo
[Applause]
theodore jeffrey hague
lauren jessica harris
kieran hassan
[Applause]
grace worthington javelin
james clayton hebert
yima ho
audrey yin gang
dana norbert joseph
sam katz
unique cion kim
lee
kaylee
[Applause]
michael davidson lyndon
[Music]
vivian mayers
lucy mcewen
[Music]
kathy maymon
[Music]
maxwell tyler modell
[Applause]
jack morton
[Applause]
keaton irving mueller
allison mina park
maya chakrabarti passaic
thomas clark pointer
[Music]
[Applause]
carolina lima porcilla
thomas arthur grant kejano
[Applause]
agasha karif raton
alexander james reedy
jasmine teresa rios
[Applause]
[Music]
william clarence rogers iii
ethan roman ross
[Applause]
george cariakis sabbaticakis
[Applause]
andrew scheinberg
[Applause]
[Music]
anna frances smith
[Applause]
tongue
v wintron
yeah ah
jeremy level eight
i'm glad you came
hannah verma
vaudeville ford
melinda wang melinda young wayne thank
you
liesel
hi lenahan vangerman
ethan morgan williams
alvin maurice winston ii
[Applause]
alan lee woof
andy dane von hilscheimer
allen lee wu
sorry timothy
dorje wu
[Applause]
wyatt jackson yes
[Applause]
vanessa jahweh john
graduates participating remotely
daniel chenevert grace violet chung
connor downey jonas
cavalieuskas michelle ken
ming-chan alan so
thank you
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from pearson college
for the bachelor's degree in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college and approved by
the corporation
dean chun will ask you by your official
act to confer
upon them these degrees
[Applause]
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me
i shall confer upon you the bachelor's
degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
karina zao the banner bearer of pearson
college
royce penn lee and nigel connor wade
the procession marshals of pearson
college
adriana ruby arcia
aishwarya bhattacharya
jonathan bulafin
veronica chen
justin huang chang
brandon nicholas cobb
alexis caroline cook
charlotte grace cooperman
quincy montgomery crawford iv
kimberly cruz bustamante
alec die
kimberly dao
claire m davidson
[Music]
gregory dimitri dulles
ian akira denzer
victoria l dembrowick
edward and dorobek
rebecca catalina drachmann
alana simone island
matthew louis fantazi
matthew l ferraro
benjamin seoul friedman
jonathan patrick frith jr
alexandra christon godren
courtney elizabeth greene
ariana lena harrison
frederick howard hanser
oscar hedeen
kristen elizabeth henry
william who
grace jen
thomas george johnson
[Music]
emily elizabeth kilfoil
lucas jungmin kim
lauren elizabeth victoria lee
jaylen everlay leone
joy lyanne
lee josephy logan
melissa dai lou
victoria wendy mack
muhammad amir mahmudof
katie mallison
orvin frey alvaro mayari
nora c moreau
dan l nguyen
kevin david o'neal
christine marie oberhausen
mike howie o'gego
adeji oh palmer
nandan vinu patel
camille vien bam
lauren dawn finney
sophie d pollock
sebastian burundi rugunda quaid
lauren ashley quintella
caleb foyer rhodes
joseph rivaldo
jared brandon rock
ursula lucila rodriguez
bartoloma bartolomeo rondelli
nilam
[Music]
isabel sophia sans
thomas henry chucked
young min shin
taylor spidori
eliana rose swerdlow
nicholas victor tabio
karen yang tai
tanner john tavritsky
tyler alexander tavritzky
jason twan thompson
camille ellen umoth
[Music]
daniel kenneth irkey
milan govinda vivanco
eric yang wang
todd mitchell warshawski
sherry wu
vicki wu
[Music]
vivian zoo
lillian yuan
ahmed
to the students of the class of 2021
and their parents families and friends
looking on
from around the globe
we gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments of
all of you who have worked so hard to
complete your programs of study
we salute your effort your diligence
your talent
and your intellect we also join you
in expressing gratitude for all who have
supported you in these endeavors
your families and friends and teachers
and other members of the yale community
congratulations class of 2021.
hello class of 2021 my name is curtis
calvette and i'm your class treasurer
four years have gone by in the blink of
an eye we've made so many memories
from the first year snowball fight on
old campus to the yale harvard football
game in 2019 where we won
in double overtime to all of the late
nights
whether they be in the library studying
for an exam or in the common room
talking with our friends and suitemates
although our senior year experience was
certainly not a traditional one the
class of 2021 made the best
of the situation when we leave yale in
just a few days
we will leave with memories and
friendships that will last
a lifetime here's to the class of 2021
we did it
congratulations
class of 2021 good afternoon
my name
[Applause]
my name is akhil rajin and i'm a member
of the committee that organized class
day which will air on youtube tomorrow
at 2 30 pm
two minutes before at 2 28 a special
piece written by class day speaker
robert lopez
will be played from harkness tower so
keep your ears open
and if you haven't already decorated a
funny hat for class day
it's not too late in fact on your seat
today
you received a class of 2021 hat which
you might want to use for that very
purpose you'll also find a gift bag
which includes items that represent
long-standing class day traditions as
well as a few that are unique to the
class of 2021
in addition to the class day speaker
tomorrow's program will also include
remarks by members of our class
who have put together outstanding
original speeches
and because class day is about all of us
you'll see your photographs and video
reflections throughout tomorrow's
program as well
congratulations class of 2021 and see
you tomorrow at class day
class of 2021 congratulations again i am
so happy to be with you
and celebrate with you today graduating
is such a great accomplishment
and one of the most important ones in
your life if you think back to
when you first arrived on campus no one
could have imagined that you would live
through a global pandemic
before reaching this moment but you did
and thanks to your strength and
perseverance this moment has finally
come
i am honored to recognize all the work
that you have done to get here
much of it with the support of your
family and friends
today is your day and it is theirs too
today is a day for looking back with
pride at everything you have
accomplished
and all the goals you have reached of
course it brings some sadness too
now that you are ending your bright
college years
but today is a commencement a beginning
so now as you look to the days and years
ahead
think of the new achievements and
opportunities in front of you
and look around as well to remind
yourself
of the excellent company joining you on
this new beginning
your friendships formed at yale
tomorrow you will celebrate class day a
tradition stretching back 150 years in
yell college history
i'm excited to watch the virtual program
alongside you
and on monday we can look forward to
president salovey's commencement address
i am grateful to the class day committee
to the senior class council
to to the university secretary's office
to your college heads and deans
and to everyone who contributed to
making the special events
of this weekend possible and i'm most
appreciative
to you for all that you have brought to
yale
and now will bring out into the world
with you
again class of 2021 congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
three two
[Music]
you have to come back
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you